[Music]
this is not a tough movie to get behind
and promote and be excited about because
people got some love but I love riding
this one that not pushing it we know
each other
he's a friend from work your kids
obviously think that you know what you
do is got to be the coolest thing in the
world but the fact that you play the
Hulk how does that affect your dad
stance I mean your stock has got to go
up there some over me now they love it
did they visit on set were they in us
yeah we date so I brought them with me
when we shot the movie okay and they
were they were background artists and
they were they were in it yes they were
in it there I missed out while they're
in the sack I don't know if you could
see them I to see the movie but never
dressed up as as they as the dr. Seuss
character basically they did they're
like man a great day they were there all
day long which is exactly the experience
I want them to have that's where I
wanted to know because it can seems very
glamorous you know being on set oh
you're a movie star whatever but I mean
those days get pretty long how did they
do there like I was I think it was good
[Music]
[Laughter]
one day was enough
[Music]